[Applause]
here we go
they've been too nice for too long and i
was wondering when someone on denver
was going to do something but you might
have picked the wrong person to do
something against in jay crowder
i don't mind it
but know your personnel
we got every angle covered right there
with the best
tv cameraman in the nba steve angel
corey
alberti along with ryan chapman renee
champagne alex cochran and
steve angel now are they throwing out
gordon i don't think they're throwing
alcohol i think this is a double
technical
[Applause]
[Applause]
out from poncho on top
[Applause]
double t's gordon and crowder
ayton is out on jokic six of 12
finds compazo
body was thrown out of bounds a whistle
offensive foul on gordon
gordon will pick it up frustrated
who is picked up in a trade with orlando
mid-season has had a definite impact on
this team
and certainly gives him toughness and
who picked it up jay crowder
the two guys the two principals who just
moments ago